ethiopie alerte à la sécheresse près de
3 millions de personnes menacées par la
famine
nouvelle calédonie la violence verbale
jean marie tjibaou qualifie de traîtres
les kanaks qui collaborent avec la
france le procureur de la république
ouvre une information pour provocations
et menaces
après le téléphone à quand la carte de
crédit pour les parcmètres le projet est
prêt nous l'avons testé une journée
supplémentaire de détention pour marcel
carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés
voilà monsieur bonsoir extrême urgence
danger de famine pour près de 3 millions
d'éthiopiens c'est par ces mots et ce
chiffre que commence l'appel lancé
aujourd'hui à l'opinion publique
internationale par le secours catholique
en effet après deux années relativement
fertile la pluie a de nouveau cessé de
tomber et les récoltes attendues ne
viendront pas ajouter à ce fléau naturel
les difficulté d'acheminer les secours
dans ce pays bouleversé par la guerre
civile depuis plus de dix ans maintenant
la corruption qui règne et vous aurez en
main
les principales données de la situation
3 millions d'hommes de femmes et
d'enfants menacés par la famine mais
au-delà de cette statistique éloquente
mais qui reste abstraite
ce que je vous propose ce soir c'est de
constater dans une famille de paysans ce
que signifie concrètement le mot
sécheresse et ses conséquences dominique
torrès côte dernier
à vous de jouer
les paysans du tigré en six enfants âgés
de 3 à 14 ans après deux années de répit
la sécheresse a une fois encore frappé
le nord de l'ethiopie juin juillet août
sans une goutte de pluie c'est
maintenant en octobre et novembre
je dois seraient cotées ce qui a été
semé en joie ce qui en comptent sur moi
de 10% d'une récolte normale
alors comment va-t-il nourrir toute sa
famille nous sommes en train de préparer
le déjeuner de notre famille à cause de
la sécheresse
tout ce que nous avons c'est du maïs
seulement d'umanis ici avant c'était
plein de réserves de nourriture plein
plein il y avait du blé pour faire notre
crêpes line gira mais maintenant voyez
c'est vim dans cette pièce ici j'avais
des animaux des chèvres des moutons que
j'ai vendu pour acheter de la nourriture
j'ai tout vendu et maintenant il ne me
reste plus que cet unique vaches
si vous la voyez si la seule vache que
j'ai
je vais ici un jardin de tomates de
pommes de terre de poids à cause de la
sécheresse
cette année il m'a été impossible de
cultiver cette terre si il y avait de
quoi nourrir ma famille on n'a plus rien
à cause du manque d'eau on peut plus
rien cultiver
avant cet endroit était plein d'eau
maintenant cette eau ne suffit plus à
nos besoins ni pour nous ni pour les
animaux
il faudrait une aide de gouvernementale
ce qu'il nous faut c'est un lac
artificiel il est encore temps des
solutions sont possibles
six millions d'éthiopiens vivent
aujourd'hui en sursis
les positions se radicalisent en
nouvelle calédonie où l'on est encore
heureusement qu'au stade de la guerre
des mots mais ces conséquences peuvent
être graves
en effet le procureur de la république
de nouméa a décidé d'ouvrir pour
provocations et menaces
une information à l'encontre du leader
indépendantiste jean-marie tjibaou qui a
déclaré les kanaks qui collaborent avec
la france sont des traîtres et nous
devons les traiter sans pitié ajoutant
aussitôt de même que cela ne signifiait
pas leur élimination physique
roland sicard le ton des
indépendantistes s'est brutalement durci
pourtant le congrès de l'union
calédonienne considéré comme la branche
modérée du fn la caisse devait être sans
surprise mais voilà l'acquittement des
auteurs de la fusillade le guen et la
mort d'un jeune mélanésiens tuiles ya
dix jours par les gendarmes ont pesé sur
tous les débats
un brin kanak est un kanak mort a dit
jean marie tjibaou soyez vigilants
défendez vous y venez venez on appelle
quant à lui à la résistance ont dix ans
maintenant aux gens à nogent il n'y a
pas de ces la résistance par rapport à l
occupation
organisez vous et demandez pas à
demander pas d'instruction à aux
dirigeants c'est dans ce cadre de la
résistance que ça se fait par exemple la
fin louis une partie de la tribu et
gendarmes c'est de la résistance c'est
la résistance dès samedi le rpcr avait
dénoncé ces propos les qualifiant d'
appels à la haine et d'incitation au
meurtre
aujourd'hui le procureur de la
république de nouméa requis l'ouverture
d'une information judiciaire
lil wayne et aux aînés a fait savoir
qu'il ne répondrait à aucune convocation
de l'institution qu'il ne reconnaissait
pas à beyrouth après l'explosion jeudi
dernier d'une valise piégée à l'aéroport
cinq morts l'explosion d'une boîte de
chocolats piégée elle
pita l'universitaire américain des
routes ouest hier sept morts 31 blessés
et bien c'est une véritable psychose de
l'attentât qui règne dans la capitale
libanaise qui a pourtant vous le savez
l'habitude de vivre dans l'anxiété
martine laroche-joubert ce sont d'abord
les femmes qui sont aujourd'hui fouiller
à beyrouth deux attentats en trois jours
à chaque fois c'est une femme qui porte
un colis piégé il valise à l'aéroport de
beyrouth une boîte de chocolats à
l'hôpital de l'université américaine
deux femmes blondes d'après certains
témoins drogué peut-être morte dans
l'explosion et dont l'identité reste
inconnue lui russe de plus des
terroristes on se méfie - dell a procédé
plus efficaces aussi un paquet peut
exploser n'importe où les colis remplace
aujourd'hui les voitures piégées qui
passe plus difficilement les mailles des
contrôles syrien cet ordre syrien à
beyrouth ouest la cible semble-t-il de
ces attentats non revendiqués qu'il soit
organisé par des extrémistes chrétiens
ou chiite c'est un roger tragique une
fois de plus de l'emprise de la syrie
sur le liban regain de tension dans le
conflit iran irak samedi et dimanche les
irakiens ont intensifié leurs raids
aériens au sud l'iran et à téhéran un
conseil de guerre prépare une contre
attaque que sera cette semaine sur les
places financières internationales cela
dépend en grande partie de l'accord
éventuel entre le président américain
reggane et le congrès est de son pays
sur une réduction du déficit commercial
des etats-unis est aussi une
augmentation des impôts des amériques
shaka bouchard l'accord sur la réduction
de l'énorme déficit du budget américain
qui sera conclu cette semaine
c'est en tout cas la conviction de
ronald reagan
le président annonce même un shih le
gouffre budgétaire serait réduit de 30
milliards de dollars pour deux tiers
sous forme d'économies et pour un tiers
10 milliards par une augmentation d'
imposer de taxes
c'est un coup de canif dans le contrat
passé il y à 7 ans entre monsieur
reggane et le pays à son entrée à la
maison blanche
en 1981 le président s'était engagé à ne
jamais alourdir la fiscalité
aujourd'hui n'a plus le choix le trou
budgétaire pulvérise les records - 220
milliards de dollars en 86 la récente
bourrasques de wall street et
partiellement lee
à l'impasse entre le congrès et la
maison blanche sur le budget depuis plus
de deux semaines les deux parties
discutent âprement jeudi dernier
l'accord semble être enfin acquis avant
que surgisse de nouveaux obstacles
la maison blanche veut éviter des coupes
sombres dans les crédits de la défense
les élus de l'opposition démocrates
exigent que l'on épargne les programmes
sociaux
mais les uns et les autres connaissent
l'enjeu de leurs tractations ils savent
que wall street est toujours sous le
choc du 19 octobre
le fameux lundi noir un échec des
négociations en cours pourraient donc
replongé et la bourse de new york et les
autres grandes places financières dans
une nouvelle débâcle
quand la chine s'éveillera c'est le
titre d'un ouvrage célèbre d'alain
peyrefitte ça vous le savez mais le
ministre avait-il prévu que lorsqu'elle
crl mangerait américain c'est pourtant
ce qui se passe en ce moment
le premier fast-food made in us en chine
vient de s'implanter en plein centre de
pékin
un signe évident de l'ouverture de ce
pays vers l'occident
christian quérou co du dos
elles ont osé elles ce sont les
autorités pékinoises qui ont permis
l'ouverture d'un fast food américain à
moins de 200 mètres du mausolée de mao
quelle révolution pour ces nouveaux
consommateurs qui découvre un autre goût
venus d'ailleurs
ainsi passons sans y prendre garde des
rades les chinois au hamburger de la
soupe au poulet frit et de la fameuse
paire de baguettes à la fourchette bien
française maniez avec une certaine
maladresse
ça coûte cher parce que c'est pas cher
mais j'avais centre est trop bas comme
ça hein dis bienvenue
mais combien de près en propre en fait
un faux procès
pour les chinois c'est quelque chose
révolution aussi car le fast food et
elle abat un plaisir haut de gamme que
l'on peut s'offrir avec parcimonie
mystérieuse affaire de rapt d'enfant en
espagne la petite fille d'une célèbre
chanteuse d'opéra rock sud coréenne kim
era a été enlevé la semaine dernière les
auteurs de l'enlèvement pourrait être
connue de son mari un milliardaire
libanais la princesse kymera a lancé un
appel aux ravisseurs
patrice benoit xi à la télévision
espagnole l'appel de la dernière chance
pour retrouver mélodies 5 ans enlevé il
ya une semaine sur le chemin de l'école
quatre hommes armés et masqués très peu
d'indicés pour les policiers leur
enquête s'oriente vers les anciennes
relations d'affaires du père de mme
elodie raimond aka chiant un riche
libanais des relations d'affaires plutôt
trouble certains de ses anciens associés
seraient compromis dans un trafic d'or
et de diamants dans un scandale
immobilier aussi vendredi la famille a
accepté de payer une rançon
un milliard de pesetas ce un peu plus de
50 millions de francs
et depuis hier raymond à cachan utilise
larmes des ravisseurs de sa fille le
chantage
il a lui même fixé un ultimatum si mardi
mélodies n'est pas libéré plus question
de rançon plus question de céder version
des policiers la famille connaît les
ravisseurs elle aurait même négocier
avec eux par l'intermédiaire de la mafia
cet après midi l'avocat de la princesse
kymera a promis 300 mille francs pour
toute information et écarté l'hypothèse
d'un rapt politique la politique
maintenant pourquoi pas premier ministre
de raymond barre si celui ci est élu
président avec une très large majorité
cette petite phrase du socialiste
jacques delors a vraiment frappé très
fort et l alimenter le week-end
politiques français pascal guimier
chez jacques barrot barriste un oui mais
à jacques delors des hommes nouveaux
seraient les bienvenus chez raymond
barre à condition toutefois qu'ils
rompent les amarres de leur socialisme
originel socialisme justement paul
quilès qui envisage lui une toute autre
hypothèse après la présidentielle il y
aura bien un regroupement des forces
politiques une recomposition à droite
mais seulement si françois mitterrand
est à l'elysée michel rocard de son côté
souligner les différences entre les
politiques du ps et de raymond barre une
manière feutrée de désavouer jacques
delors pierre bérégovoy lui enfonce le
clou et le rassemblement qui est affaire
doit d'abord se faire à partir de son
camp mais une alliance gauche droite ne
paraît pas possible dernier socialiste a
parlé aujourd'hui jean poperen une
attaque frontale veut dire que le
camarade de leur a fait très fort alors
j'ai lu qu'il brouillait les pistes
je crois surtout qu'il brouille la ligne
ou qu'ils essaient ils essaient de
brouiller la ligne de partage entre la
gauche et la droite
enfin andré lajoinie communiste il
renvoie les deux camps dos à dos pour
lui jacques delors a dit tout haut ce
que beaucoup au ps pensent tout bas
la déclaration de jacques delors c'est
un peu la partie émergée de l'iceberg
et elle ne doit pas faire oublier la
partie immergée de l'iceberg
qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie
immergée de l'iceberg je m'explique
c'est la position fondamentale de la
direction du parti socialiste il ne faut
pas oublier en préparant et maintenant
le congrès de lille c'est bien le
dernier congrès du parti socialiste
l'hypothèse est la possibilité d'une
alliance du parti socialiste avec la
droite a été formellement exprimé est
adoptée par le comité directeur et j'y
ajoute parce que j'y repense à l'instant
cette métaphore d'alain madelin le
ministre de l'industrie qui ne croit pas
lui à de l'or en bas
si vous avez compris le jeu non c'est un
rêve vieux de deux cent trente six ans
qui va véritablement prendre corps à
partir de mercredi puisque la société
eurotunnel chargée de la construction du
tunnel sous la manche proposera des
actions au prix
de 35 francs l'unité le même jour en
angleterre et en france
si le public achète malgré la mauvaise
conjoncture actuelle de la bourse les
banques confirmeront alors leur prête et
dès lors rien ne pourra plus empêcher
l'achèvement du tunnel
françoise joly le tunnel sous la manche
se moque de la tempête alors même que le
calme est loin d'être revenue sur les
marchés financiers eurotunnel
s'introduit en bourse une souscription
qui porte sur plus de 7 milliards et
demi de francs dès mercredi à 35 francs
l'unité 3 milliards et demi de titres
vont être proposés à paris autant à la
city le reste sur le marché
international une opération qui
s'annonce plus difficile que prévu déjà
certains investisseurs internationaux se
font moins gourmands
c'est le cas notamment des japonais le
tunnel sous la manche est entièrement
financé par des fonds privés pour sa
réalisation eurotunnel emprunte
également 50 milliards de francs
la liaison entre la france et
l'angleterre sera établi en 1993
à cette date grâce aux navettes
ferroviaires moins de 35 minutes seront
nécessaires pour traverser la manche
mais d'ici là il faut creuser 50
kilomètres de tunnels et surtout
franchir le cap de cette entrée en
bourse
un an après ou presque après les
manifestations étudiantes contre la loi
devaquet en 86 les lycéens de la région
parisienne devrait manifester mercredi
prochain contre les classes surchargées
tandis que les étudiants eux défileront
le jeudi de la semaine suivante toujours
à paris mais cette fois ci contre le
budget universitaire en 1988 cette
décision était prise par la coordination
réunis ce week end à paris voilà une
histoire que se répéteront pendant
longtemps 189 perroquet colombien
exportés illégalement et qui transitait
par l'aéroport de roissy
ces oiseaux qui font partie d'une espèce
protégée et rare représente une valeur
de 7 millions de francs j'ai bien dit 7
millions de francs
les douanes françaises ont intercepté la
cargaison le ministre de l'environnement
monsieur alain carignon en personne
s'est déplacé et les 189 perroquet vont
être réexpédiés dès ce soir vers la
colombie gérard bon fils lors des
caisses sans eau sans nourriture ces
perroquets sont arrivés vendredi à
roissy en provenance de colombie et
après sept heures de transit ils
devaient être réexpédié vers bornéo
sur intervention du service des douanes
constatant l'absence de documents
administratifs en règle cette
exportation frauduleuse a été saisie en
référence à la convention de washington
qui régit le commerce des animaux
sauvages 500000 perroquets sont
officiellement commercialisée sur le
marché international chaque année 12000
sont importés en france par exemple
mais à ces chiffres il convient
d'ajouter les importations illégales qui
tendent à se multiplier en raison des
profits substantiels réalisés les
animaux sont des êtres vivants qui qui
souffrent qui meurt dans ces conditions
de transport on assiste là pour de
l'argent à la suppression des espèces
menacées
cela ne peut plus durer et et je crois
qu'il faut se battre touche avec les
associations concernées pour que cela
cesse les services vétérinaires de
l'aéroport de roissy qui ne possèdent
pas de structures d'accueil suffisantes
ont néanmoins soigné ses animaux effet
accélérer la procédure de retour au pays
les 189 perroquet survivants de
l'odyssée seront dès demain de retour à
bogota dans leur environnement naturel
le carnet de chèque avait remplacé
l'argent liquide
il est en passe d'être lui-même remplacé
par la carte de crédit c'est déjà vrai
dans les cabines téléphoniques par
exemple salle sera peut-être demain dans
les parcmètres si l'appareil est
actuellement expérimentée est adoptée à
paris et dans les grandes villes
françaises
alors gérard pas bio toujours en avance
sur l'information à tester cet appareil
pour vous
un nouveau parc met plus performants à
bas on avait bien besoin de ça déjà que
la voiture est une maîtresse exigeante
ça tout le monde le sait elle et
dépensière buts et même parfois futiles
coquette et surtout elle boit elle
n'arrête pas de voir
par contre elle n'est pas trop
regardante pour ce qui est du logement
on peut très facilement lui apprendre le
caniveau
or précisément le caniveau en question
devient qu'une denrée rare et kidira
richert normale et dans le théâtre de
boulevard comme c'est ici le cas
il faut toujours compter avec le
troisième personnage alors pour mettre
un peu d'ordre dans cette tragédie
classique très classique
on a donc depuis belle lurette appliquer
le principe des trois unités
le lieu le temps et l'action comme ça
tout le monde est content enfin presque
afin précisément de satisfaire tout le
monde
un organisme bienveillant vient
d'inventer la carte à temps réel portant
votre numéro minéralogique et les deux
appareils correspondant le radio parc
fixe pour la carte et le very parc
mobile à deux jambes motrices le radio
parc est en fait un vilain rapporteur
qui indique éventuellement à distance le
temps qui nous est crédité aux
distributeurs d'amande que voici par
very parc interposés vous me suivez
d'après le fabricant avec le modèle
actuel il y a beaucoup trop de temps
perdu en allées et venues imaginons par
exemple le cas du monsieur qui est un
rendez vous dont il ignore la durée
il programme donc une heure sur place il
se ravise et il rajoute du temps en
perdant bien sûr le bénéfice du ticket
précédent nouveau trajet pour constater
que le rendez-vous est annulé retour
pour tenter de récupérer l'argent du
stationnement inutile peine perdue à
présent avec la carte plus de problème
on peut programmer le maximum le temps
non utilisées et remboursés au retour un
autre avantage du système
le procès-verbal qu'on n'était jamais
jusqu alors sûr de payer toujours à la
merci d'une mauvaise écriture d'un
chiffre erroné d'une grâce
présidentielle intempestives aucun
risque cette fois avec le very parks est
imprimé sur place en est sûr de l'avoir
au mois de septembre
à 41 ans il avait obtenu une dérogation
pour participer au championnat du monde
professionnel sur christ sur route mais
pas gérard pas bio rassurez vous
aujourd'hui au terme de dix huit années
de carrière marquée principalement par
une victoire dans le tour de france et
un titre de champion du monde il
raccroche son nom yahoo hotmail qu un
landais bien de chez nous
thierry blancot 1980 dix ans après ses
débuts dans le tour c'est la victoire
est au bout de melk à 34 ans déjà mais
le plus fort c'est sans doute son titre
de champion du monde en 85
faites le calcul 39 ans époustouflant
hotmail com cette année pour la plus
grande classique belge
l'amstel gold race un véritable
phénomène mais c'est vrai qu'il a dû
attendre longtemps jacmel chute dans le
midi libre en 74 des mois pour revenir
au meilleur niveau et surtout en face de
lui
eddy merckx pas de chance après merckx
bernard hinault tout mail terminera six
fois deuxième du tour trois fois
derrière le blaireau et pour gagner
comme il l'a fait sur le tard de qualité
persévérance et obstination
ajoutez à ça une parfaite hygiène de vie
est la passion de son métier
bref l'histoire du plus français des
hollandais une star quitte le peloton
mais à 41 ans qu'est ce qui pouvait bien
encore le faire courir à part ça
justement la passion du vélo la danse
sportive c'est à la fois comme son nom
l'indiqué un art est un sport et la scea
dette au nombre de dix mille en france
est bien plus en angleterre ou en
allemagne de l'ouest
hier soir à cergy pontoise avait lieu le
championnat de france en piste delphine
de la selle
d'abord il y à des passes de tous les
jours et puis il ya le rythme celui que
l'on n'oublie pas et ce plaisir à deux
qui font que c'est pas mille fois
répétés fini ce temps spectacle de
lumière
quand on rentre à l'école de danse la
journée de boulot elle est passée on ne
pense plus à table on sait la soirée
dedans et puis bon bacon se rendent chez
moi c'est la même chose là dedans c'est
oublier c'est un nouvel heures une
nouvelle vie en fait oman plusieurs via
la fois ces travaux répondent très
amusant
c'est un sport artistique il ya sport
car il ya compétition championnat
entraînement artistique parce que c'est
quand même de la danse il ya la musique
le rythme et les chorégraphies être
champion ne s'improvise pas il faut des
jours des mois des années d'entraînement
de complicité et de passion commune
travaille et retravaille et son lukaku
de paillettes de muhsin de strass 4000
en france plusieurs centaines de
milliers en europe y sacrifie temps
travail loisirs et économie l'apparence
pour le public et c'est quelque chose de
primordial près d'oublier qu'il a tant
que ça en fait une un coupleur noces
mozilla un couple est très attrayant de
laval sont passant par la samba
il y en a un sport un sport véritable
avec ces amateurs ces règles ces
championnats et ses professionnels
les étoiles sont très nets tokyo et à
new york et la mecque de la danse
sportive reste blackpool théâtre du
british open
c'est une très grande compétition où
tous les couples étrangers se retrouvent
au mois de mai pendant une semaine et
c'est gigantesque c'est incroyable c'est
cette extraordinaire s'est même pas
qualifié à tellement c'est beau tango
ravageur rumba lascive cette discipline
délicieusement rétro si aux années 80
seuls quelques-uns deviendront
professionnels n'est qu'importe s'ils
ont déjà le regard le look et l'élégance
qui va nous faire rêver
si vous voulez vous pouvez continuer à
danser moi je ne peux pas je présente le
journal et en l'occurrence le tiercé de
ce soit avec ses résultats qui vont
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour gagner
aujourd'hui
il fallait jouer hélas le 2 et le 6 ça
rapporte 100 de francs et pas cher payé
100 de francs 5 ans et puis il y avait
un quarté + je crois aussi qu'il va
s'inscrire derrière voilà carte est
derrière l'as le 2 le 6 le 8 288 rend
visiblement tous les favoris étaient à
l'arrivée on va prendre des nouvelles de
la météo maintenant avec les prévisions
de sophie mais c'est le cadet dia daniel
le sait le rat meilleure mine demain
tout simplement parce que les nuages
présents le matin vont se déchirer car
la perturbation qui affectait la france
aujourd'hui déjà va perdre de son
activité au profit d'un anticyclone
gonfle à nouveau au sud du pays
résultat est bien le soleil pointera le
bout du nez sur l'aquitaine sur le sud
ouest ainsi que sur le nord ouest en
alternance avec quelques averses les
éclaircies un petit peu plus généreuse
sur les régions méditerranéennes
la perturbation on la retrouve sur les
pays de loire sur le centre le massif
central le nord-est les vosges et les
alpes elle donne encore quelques chutes
de neige au dessus de 1500 mètres les
températures prévues pour demain nous
sont sans grand changement par rapport à
aujourd'hui on s'échelonnent de 9° à
charbon jusqu'à 12 degrés à tours ainsi
qu'à nantes et de 10 degrés à lyon et à
clermont ferrand jusqu'à 18 degrés en
corse
demain nous serons le lundi 16 novembre
nous perdrons quatre minutes de soleil
et nous fêterons les marguerites superbe
de ma fille ce soir le policier du
dimanche vaines recherches sur antenne 2
et puis demain je vous le signale
télématin aura lieu en direct du
restaurant drouant aura lieu quelques
heures plus tard la remise du prix
littéraire le plus connu le prix
goncourt et puis ce soir je n'oublie pas
en fin de programme vous retrouverez
philippe gassot quant à moi si vous
voulez bien on se retrouve le week-end
prochain
bonsoir excellente semaine sur antenne 2
bien sûr roi